this next door, he really bothers me.
Um,
mm.
The Trump administration has instituted a
new rule that would give homeless shelters
the ability to turn away trans people, Trans
Women, and Trans a trans men, uh, as significantly.
MMM.
Disturbing.
When you consider the number, uh, are the
percentage of trans individuals are trans
people who are homeless at some point in their
lives.
I believe the percentage is around one third,
one out of three trans people will be homeless
at some point in their life.
And the Trump administration has upon itself
to give shut homeless shelters.
The option.
Previously the Obama Administration, uh, took
away that ability in order to protect trans
people.
Uh, and this is what Donald Trump is doing.
In response.
I want to read the actual a rule.
This is the actual rule.
Um, uh, that they are instituting it says
quote, the proposed rule permits shelter providers
to consider a range of factors and making
such determinations including privacy, safety,
practical concerns, religious beliefs, and
any considerations under civil rights and
nondiscrimination authorities and relevant
considerations rather, uh, the individuals
sex as reflected in official government documents
as well as the gender, which a person identifies
with the proposed rule does not dictate a
required basis for making determinations other
than they be consistent with an overall policy.
So that last line is the kicker, right?
The hand is pretty bad.
But the kicker is the fact that the rules,
uh, will not require any basis for making
these determinations.
Just so long as you have some rules written
out.
So long as you have a consistent overall policy
of discrimination, it's totally okay for you
to discriminate against Trans people and lead
them out in the cold, uh, homeless because
we have, uh, a, an unbelievable amount of
homeless people in general, but a unbelievable
percentage of trans individuals who are at
some point in their life.
I'm homeless, but it's cool.
So long as you have that policy written down
according to the Trump administration, uh,
I want to read some, one responds to it.
Uh, the proposal published Wednesday would
roll back Obama era protections to prevent
single-sex shelters from discriminating on
the basis of sexual orientation and gender
identity.
So this particularly comes into play for shelters
that are single gender.
Here's the thing, and how conservatives will
always spend this and have always spun this.
They always spend this as the bid bag, big,
bad boogeyman trans woman who sneaks into
a bathroom, a woman's bathroom, to do something
nefarious.
And insidious, right?
But they completely neglect the fact that
if you put a trans woman into an all male
facility, then they themselves are exposed
to tremendous violence and violation.
And so they never give any regard to the life
of that individual.
And they always create this boogie man, this,
this the straw man of an argument to say that,
you know, if you put a trans person in a trans
woman and a woman's bathroom or in a woman's
facility, homeless shelter, then something
terrible is going to happen.
When we see there is data that underscores
the fact that trans women are being murdered
and an unbelievable rate.
Another quote under the Department of Housing
and urban development rule change, homeless
shelter operators could create a policy to
consider it an individual's sex for the purposes
of determining accommodation within such shelters
and for the purposes of determining sex for
admission to another facility, any facility
or portion thereof.
And finally, nearly one third of transgender
Americans who responded to a 2015 a survey
had experienced homelessness in their lifetime.
So this is a, a, an extremely serious event.
And a rule change and what it's going to force,
um, trans individuals to do trans people,
to do trans women, to have, to go, in order
to get out of the code, they will have to
go to an all male facility because they're
government documents it, right?
They're going to go all the way back to the
government documents probably before their
sex change, probably for their gender change,
and they're going to be forced to live and
to go to shelters based on what's on that
document.
So it's adding insult to injury.
It's, it's, it's, it's clearly, um, it's,
it's just one of the, it's one of the unnecessarily
cruel things that this administration is doing.
I've got stories back to back today that demonstrate
the level of cruelness that this government
is operating in a, for the most part, it is
highlighted.
It's exacerbated, um, by the Trump administration.
Uh, but some of it has carried over from the
Obama administration.
Uh, and you'll see that in the next story.
But this, this story, this story right here
is 100% laid at the feet of Donald Trump and
all the conservative Christian evangelicals
who are obsessed with sexuality, uh, obsessed
with their definition of morality, their definition
of what is traditional and, and absolutely
rob, anyone else have the opportunity to define
what traditional is for themselves or to define
their own sexual morality or to define their
own sexual identity.
And they want to compel the rest of the world,
the rest of the nation and the world to live
according to their interpretation of their
religious texts.
That's what this is about.
And as usual, the victims in this are the
most marginalized people in our country, across
the world.
It never fails when an evangelical Christian
thing happens in this country.
Politically, the victims are always some of
the most marginalized people.
One out of three transgender Americans will
experience homelessness is some point in their
lifetime.
And now they have to choose whether or not
to go to a facility that, um, to a facility
with which they don't identify gender wise
or stay out in the cold.
God bless America, right?